hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast simple fast and accurate
microbial identification by sequencing I
am Judy Oracle blab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by lab roots calm
her reading social media site for
science professionals and sponsored by
SCI x placing the power of life-changing
answers into the hands of those who care
everywhere before we start there are a
few instructions we want to hear from
you during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions will leave us a
comment answers are welcome to you can
do this by hitting the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments or
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if you don't
have time today want a better look you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button on the top right or use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issues now let's get right
to today's presenter we are proud to
welcome dr. Jane moooo dr. glow is a
staff application scientist at sai x
responsible for developing genomic
applications on sy x capillary
electrophoresis product lines within her
role as an application scientist she
works closely with key opinion and
thought leaders to gain insight on in
relevance and utility of various genetic
applications prior to joining sigh X she
was a chemistry development scientist at
beckman coulter who led development of
several reagent and chemistry kits used
on the genome lab j exp genetic analysis
system previously she was a scientist at
allergan working on anti
hypercholesterolemia drugs and an
assistant adjunct professor at UC irvine
studying anti-vegf therapy for human
pancreatic cancer dr. glow received her
PhD in biochemistry from Hunter College
of the City University of New York and
received postdoctoral training at
Cornell University met
college in harvard medical school and
children's hospital in boston i will now
turn it over to dr. Lowe thank you very
much to do good morning good afternoon
and good evening today I would like to
talk about simple fast and accurate
microbial identification by sequencing
why is microbial contaminants
identification important well if food is
contaminated where is bad bacteria
people will get sick when they eat it
with patients take the pharmaceutical
drug products that is contaminated they
will suffer adverse effects or
complications nowadays we all try to
live a healthier life by doing something
good to ourselves such as taking by your
profile pills that will help us to
improve our digestion each probiotic
pill contains 10 billion bacteria can
you imagine what ever happen if that
probiotic field is contaminated with
that bacteria you can get really sick
the products are complete terminated
with microbes manufacturers will have
compliance issue with fda gaiden and iso
standards let's take a look at at the
impact of microbial contamination on
quality leave the starter culture of a
milk products such as yogurt is
contaminated with a different micro
organism the yogurt may not taste the
way you like same is true for beer
production if product is contaminated
with microorganisms they're usually have
to be scrapped increasing the product
costs if
the products were not called during QC
testing and release to customers they
will have to be done with the recall and
any record is bad for any company
because it projects a very bad image for
the quality of the products I think we
all understand and agree that microbial
contaminated education is very important
we left a guideline for industry
released in 2004 for industry on stereo
drug products produced by aseptic
processing FDA recommended that any
contaminated unit should be considered
objectionable and investigated the
microorganisms should be identified to
species level so how do we identify
microbial contaminants first let's look
at the traditional methods for microbial
identification most of them are based by
phenotypic differences of different
microorganisms the cultural method is
very common the microbes are growing on
different type of agar plates this
method is very inexpensive and easy to
do Gram stain can be used to determine
if a bacterium is gram positive or gram
negative there are many different types
of biochemical analysis available from
an individual test tubes that contains
different carbon source to plastic
strips with individual test solutions
packaged in the bubble wrap format some
vendors offer 96-well plate with
different common sources / well other
vendors provides semi-automated or fully
automated and militarized tests these
cars are usually very straightforward
follow and
to perform they are also mainly
immunological tests available for some
of the organizers let's look at the
limitation of traditional methods for
micro microfilm identification very
often they cannot identify
microorganisms down to species level the
culture method usually take a moment
privation time they are incapable of
differentiating highly related species
usually they are labor-intensive and not
automation friendly the gram staining
our prey to your operator error not
automation friendly the biochemical
analysis usually cannot differentiate
related species with similar biochemical
properties and very often they're
inconclusive the immunology contests are
not available for all microorganisms so
you may want ask any other lands next
how about the test based on molecular
biology well that's exactly what I'm
going to talk about today microbe
microbial identification by sequencing
which gene to sequence we recommend
sequencing ribosomal RNA gene right
level serve on our energy ribosomal RNA
is an important molecule which is part
of my labors of ribosomes are protein
factories in ourselves do tree is
important function R episode I'm a genie
of the cord our DNA is the most
conserved emailing ourselves the RNA
sequence from distantly related
organisms can be precisely aligned to
readily identify the true differences
between them in chrome currently
microorganisms such as Nicole I and
streptococcus there are three different
title ribosomal RNA
there are 16 s 23 s and 5 s the 16s rdna
23 as our DNA and a 5 as are you I
always seem the same opera they are
transcribed together please reach in
between the vase 16s and 23s it's called
IGS one or intergenic spacer region one
and then the region between 23 s and the
5s it's called IGS to some other
scientists also whole ideas in a
different name as i TS internally
transcribed spacer region both IGS and i
ts are correct terms and used by
different scientists in their
publications among the three reversible
rd the most conserved one is a 16s rdna
at the lower part of this slide you will
see a bar representing 16s rdna it's
about 1500 base pair long the red region
represents conserve the region that can
be used to align 16s rdna from different
microorganisms the blue region
represents the variable region which are
usually group or species-specific they
can be used to identify micro levels
down to species level if we look at the
eukaryotic microorganisms they have four
different are Eileen the 18s 5.8 s 26 s
and 5 s the 18s rdna and the 5.8 s our
DNA and 26s our DNA are transcribed
together the 5s are delay is made
separately by a different I'll
equivalence the link in between
the 18s and the 5.8 s it's called LTS
one or internally transcribed spacer
region 1 and the space between the
five-point s and 26s it's called 80s to
right in front of the HMS is the ETS one
which is stands for externally
transcribed spacer region 1 and then
behind 26 s is the ETS tree for
microbial identification scientists have
used 18s rdna sequences some other
scientists also used I ts14 IDs to you
that even d1 d2 region in the 26s over
the past 10 years microbial
identification by our domestic wilson
has become a fast and inexpensive
alternative to traditional methods
especially the 16 as our DNA sequencing
it can classify inside a bacteria into
different species level in addition it
was also used to describe species that
have never been successfully cultured
the identity of my cochlea
identification I remember so no harm
agency crisil over the traditional
methods are they are fast and accurate
they are capable of identifying my pole
microorganisms to species level also
they're increasing number of sequence
being added to the databases they are
multiple ribosomal RNA gene database
available in the US we have NCBI Europe
we have been and will be in Japan we
have DD bj and in us we also have our DP
which stands for ribosomal database
project there are also various
databases that are available to the
perfect in use at this point I would
like to introduce microbial
identification using genome lab G exp
genetic analysis system get your result
is in eight hours this slide shows the
flow through both the my kugel
identification using Kingdom lab gxp
genetic analysis system this workflow is
very simple and fast first you are
isolated genomic DNA from your sample
then you amplify your target in my
thermal cycler after quick post a stair
climber you do the sequencing on the gxp
system using the sequencing Kate would
provide it and then the separation and
the data analysis are fully automated
the sequence are used to identify the
micro organisms let's take a look at
workflows that buys that using the 16s
rrna gene sequencing as an example the
first step is to extract the genomic DNA
from your sample they are very there are
a lot of different options you can use
for gram-negative bacteria and
mycoplasma a quick cell lysis is good
enough basically you pick up some cells
from a single comedy or perfect cells
from 50 might be the liquid culture that
pulley from a single colony and then you
resuspend the cells in a hungry Mike
Linden water place it in boiling water
bath for 10 minutes spin briefly to
precipitate the degree and the
supernatant can be used as DNA template
for PCR alternatively you can use
magnetic beads based extraction methods
which would be suitable for both
gram-positive
and gram-negative bacteria and the
example we're recommending is the
technical term manufactured at import
Jenna fine with chili for fungus samples
we recommend using silica based being
common format isolation kit the second
step is to do PCR application of 16s
rdna basically your mix water buffer DNA
polymerase DNT p prime a mixture and
sample together and place them in the
thermal cycler you have two options for
target amplification first you can
amplify them in four lines which will
generate a complete sequence for higher
discriminating power in identifying
micro organism you can also generate
partial sequence that will take shorter
cycle in time for fast cleaning rivers
on the right side of this slide you will
see an agarose gel image of the
applicants from the PCR reaction in the
center lane we have the molecular weight
marker or size standard on the right
blame you have the four lines pcr
product which is about 1500 based care
law in the left side in the left lane
you will see the pressure sequence
that's about 800 base pair the third
step is the post-pc RK luster many of us
know that post please sir cleanup is a
critical step for the successful
implication of the thumbs training
amplifications the post physically not
method we recognize is the magnetic
beads based etching court and pure XP
manufactured by that one quarter it is
very simple to use takes less than 15
minutes to
to do and it generates high quality DNA
with no pilot is a no sword carry over
so very briefly you add edging code
beings solution to your sample letter to
bind for 50 minutes after delays bounce
to the metallic beads you place your
tube or place on a magnetic for two
minutes and then Nene magnetic beads
founder the DNA will be separated from
the rest of the solution which contains
the primers the prima donna alien queen
race and the soft after separation you
can aspirate a creative solution with a
Phi pad or a vacuum after that you watch
the beads with seventy percent SM and
may be there for half a minute and then
US / 8 as the wash solution and the
elution buffer inside the elution buffer
the DNA will be released from the
magnetic beads and then you can transfer
the energy the DNA from the tube to on
youtube so very fast simple process
there's other options to such as silica
based spin column format both adequate
and chrome Tech offers excellent spin
home kit they are excellent for
isolating piece our applicants from
Equestria and this is expectedly useful
if your PCR and the cone is not clear if
you have more than one band then you can
separate them on others gel and then cut
out your favorite band and then
extracted in made from the Equestria the
first step is to sequence the target
very fast that you assemble the
sequencing reaction using the dye
terminator cycle sequencing kit from
beckman folder
sine X and then you place the reaction
in a thermal cycler after quick clean up
missing print stick provided by vacuum
important then the fragments can be
saturated on the gxp instrument using
capillary electrophoresis after
separation and data analysis you can
take the DNA sequence to ncbi database
to do a blast search to identify the
microorganism before we move on let's
look at some important technical details
first what our diet labeled tidy oxy
terminators first let's look at the
normal deoxyribonucleotide structure on
the upper left corner of this slide
shows the structure of a rumor in oxy
ribonucleotide it has three parts the
base which can be any one of the 80 or
gyasi the deoxyribose which is a sugar
in Irwin structure and the phosphate for
simplicity we're showing it as a model
class babe usually de has three
phosphates called tried husband why do
we call it the oxy rebels that's because
deoxyribose is missing the oxygen that's
present on the second carbon atom and in
sugar ring in comparison to the regular
rivals that's present in all RNA
molecules notice that in making
accelerators sugar lean on the third
carbon position there's a hydroxy group
connecting to this carbon atom and is
colored in red on this slide this
hydroxy group is very important for the
formation of phosphodiester bond indeed
if you look at the right side of this
life you receive structure of DNA strand
and then you will realize that the oxy
revenue per type is the basic unit of
DNA molecules differently oxy
ribonucleotides are connected by
phosphodiester bonds in the polymerase
can use the oxy ribonucleotide to grow
the chain longer and longer and based on
base pairing rules squeeze the
toothpaste rat let's look at the
structure of thigh the oxy verbal
ecotype which is allocated at the lower
left corner of this slide here you can
see that the by the oxy really protein
structure looks almost exactly the same
as the New York's level meter time
however instead of having a hydroxyl at
the third carbon position in dialogue
see revenue you tight it has a hydrogen
group therefore the deal I Kremlin's can
still recognize the dialogues event on
you to type can still include
incorporated into the growing Dina chain
however the chain returning late after
the addition of this divey oxy Luca tied
because it cannot form phosphodiester
bond therefore we call a
deoxyribonucleotides as terminators
because once they get onto the DNA the
chain trim minutes the diet labeled by
the oxy terminators are the tie
deoxyribonucleotides with a dye attached
to the base it will use a different line
attached to each one of the four
different bases by the detection of the
dial we will know which base it's at the
end of terminating in a chain let's keep
that in mind we move to the next level
this slide shows Thunder tonight
Terminator psychos degrees it all starts
with reaction mixture that's
made from DNA template this sequence of
primate the anxiety which is a demon
hundreds and there'd be any degrees
which stands for dr see you correctly
sign your nucleoside triphosphate we
have four of them TCG and a and we also
have four die terminators TCG and a
witch dye terminator is labored means
any week for the lesson time while
sweetest and from this reaction replace
it in as thermal cycler so what's
happily in the thermal cycler well we
repeat a three-step procedure 30 times
the first step is the denaturation step
in which at a high temperature we
separate the pelvis candidate in one
went to two strands the complementary
strengths and template strength the
second step is an earring step you
release that will know the temperature
so that sickness and primer can anneal
at the specific location the template
strength the third step is the
extensions that where we increase the
temperature to the optimal temperature
at which that in the pre-race can
perform the best the new pre race will
incorporate the DNT piece into growing
diamond chain and making think doing the
milliner in a bunker however due to the
presence of diet terminators the chain
could terminate at any position after
the primer due to the presence of the
Terminator therefore after 30 cycles of
this three-step procedure we make a
private mixture which contains different
DNA fragments with different amends or
size each one of them it's labeled with
the die at the end of the fragment
so for summer secrecy the foundation is
based on the selective incorporation of
terminators or the dialogue see
terminators by latina polymerase if we
separate these products are capillary
electrophoresis the unwise data will
look like the data showing on the lower
right corner of this slide now let's
look at sequencing needs in capillary
electrophoresis capillaries are hollow
glass tubes with a very narrow inner
diameter they are as thin as your hair
usually the outer side is coated with a
chemical court for the image to make the
capillary more durable more strong and
more flexible if you feel a capillary
with buffer and place two ends in buffer
bias and apply electricity the eunuch
use wasting the capillary will move
based on their charge to mass ratio in
order for sequencing on capillary
electrophoresis to work we need to
remember three important points the
first important point is that the inner
wall of the capillary has to be coated
to prevent the electroosmotic flow the
electroosmotic flow moves in the
opposite direction from the direction of
DNA movement therefore the inner wall of
the capital e needs to be coded so that
many molecules can move in the right
direction and it is the right speed not
affected by electroosmotic flow the
second important point is that only lay
molecules are they have the same charge
to mass ratio therefore the capillary
needs to be filled with
saving matrix to provide separation by
size so the second important point of
sequencing using capillary
electrophoresis is that being on the
inside of a capillary needs to be filled
with a speeding matrix on the gxp system
we use the linear polyacrylamide gel
which offers high resolution is
separating and demeaning of molecules by
size the third important point is that
the fluorescently labeled edina
fragments separated by size needs to be
detected so that by the presence of the
for the resin dial we can't decide which
phase is present at the end of each
fragment now with all the technical
details explained it is only logical
that the gene XP system is very
instantaneous on this slide we show you
five basic operator steps first you
start the capillary array then use
though the gel cartridge then third
style you load several plates and a
buffer clean and then you set up your
sample plate with the software and start
the run sample separation and analysis
are fully automated our gene XP system
after the run is finished you can come
back and look at your theta let me point
out that each capillary array contains
eight capillaries which will provide
your data for each samples make it fast
and then the window and a ready fetal
side is the side where the fluorescent
infection is conducting this slide shows
how signals and data look like at the
bottom of the slide shows the raw data
we reach
preferably in considered smaller than a
fragment migrated faster than longer
fragment which comes out later on the
top panel of this slide shows the
analyzed data in an electropherogram
format and then in which you can see we
envision die clicks and above each
individual die please is sharing the
basis corresponding to the planks the
second panel shows the cross core which
stands for the meaning of the base
calling quality of the sequence data and
in the third box it shares linking the
sequence of these data once you have it
in a sequence you can go to instil a
website to select nucleotide blast and
then on blast search website you can
copy and paste your assembled sequence
in this top box unit choose 16s rrna
sequence database and then select mega
blast and then click lust you are
getting results returned in a minute or
two and the upper panel shows the
alignment scores and the lower panel in
the table in terms of description of the
microcosm that contains the sequence
that has high homology to the input
sequence if the identity is over
ninety-nine percent and the claret
coverage is over ninety-nine percent
most likely this Michael Orgeron is the
microorganism in your sample let's look
at some examples in this example we show
the sequence data from a bacillus
contaminates
nursing in this slide we sequenced the
18s rdna from the east contaminants in a
beverage sample we also try to type the
east with culture method the culture
method indicated this is a wild
Instagram or Canada per se but the
sequencing information until that visits
a lot of type 2 wild is too or candida
tropicalis by doing another method XP
pleaser on the gxp system we confirmed
that this containment was a world is to
canada tropicalis this is a great
example showcased the capability of the
GX cream genetic analysis system who
accurately identifying be microbial
contaminants from the sample on this
slide we show you the results from one
of our customers publication our
international journal of systemic
evolution airy microbiology they
followed a very simple step generically
genomic DNA was extracted from sample
16s RNA was amplified by pcr please and
become worse sequence sequence was
submitted for last surge in ncbi
database and sequence similarity
information was used to generate the
phylogenetic tree and on the left side
of this slide shows the phylogenetic
tree that was constructed using 16 as
sequencing information and a new string
mycoplasma and for informing was
identified
now let's discuss the challenges we're
still microbial identification using 16s
RNA sequencing multiple copies of 16 our
DNA could be present in one bacterium
leading to multiple labels label types
for single organism in this case single
copy cows keeping genes such as our
canopy can be sequence to provide
complementary information mixture of
bacteria and other microbes sometimes
your sample has a major that contains
bacteria beautiful colors in this case
terminal rflp or XP Casilla can be used
for analysis of this moisture some
microbes grow very slowly in this case
we can also use XP PC analysis for this
sample a little character sample using a
filtration method members of some
general or species have ninety nine
point five percent similarities to each
other for the 16s ID in this case in the
genic spacer region can be sequenced to
provide additional information rainbow
typing and multilocus sequence typing
may also be useful traditional
photochemical tests can also be used on
a slide will show you that they are
other applications that can be conducted
on the genome lab g XP genetic analysis
system multiplex expect easier multiplex
expertise here is a pcr strategy that
uses universal primal technology we can
be used for the first screen of no micro
organisms MLP a is commonly used
stop typing typical football packaging
by public house labs for outbreak
surveillance terminal rflp and AFL team
upgrade from microbial diversity
analysis I'll community studies multi
locus sequence typing and available
typing they are good for identification
of novel microbial species you can also
perform multiplexing detection on the
genome FG excrete genetic analysis
system and the multiplex near detection
is based on single base extension method
can also perform multiplex str detection
in summerlin son our sequencing is going
accurate and reliable than traditional
microbial identification methods
capillary electrophoresis analysis of
16s RNA sequence a simple fast and
accurate other molecule willing to learn
microbial identification and screening
applications can be performed on genome
lab GXP genetic analysis system that
concludes my presentation and I would
like to turn it to Julie for questions
excellent presentation dr. Rowe thank
you for bringing that information to us
before we get started with all of your
questions here's a quick reminder about
how to reach us today questions can be
sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll get to as many as we can the first
question is can the GE XP detect
multiple microbial contaminants
absolutely yes um with the multiple
contaminants we can use terminal RF
algae and xq pcr for detection of the
multiple microbial contaminants in the
same thank you the next question we
often encounter on cultural microbes
such as virus can the G exp be used to
screen viral contaminants absolutely G
exp can be used the screen slow-growing
fighters with XP PC are we need only a
very little amount of DNA sample perform
an analysis so they are excellent for
detecting the virus sample that grows
slowly thank you and next question
please if there is a mix of
microorganism in our sample sequencing
cannot work the sample must be cultured
and it may take time as well so how can
we compare sequencing approaches to the
conventional methods in terms of
increasing or I'm sorry decreasing
analysis time that's correct if you have
a mixture of bacteria you cannot use
great secrecy to identify them and we
offer three options such as terminal
rflp the XP PC our technology and also
you can do sequencing after you
construct a DNA library with the rdna
obstacles that we
from the mixture of bacteria will we
compare the sequencing with the culture
method we usually try to compare them in
terms of how fast it can identify the
microcosm down to the species level
thank you and next question please for
the post-pc are clean up using the
audience or and pure XP what is the
beads / DNA template ratio that is used
in the process the ratio is one to one
point eight so for ten microliter of
your sample you had 18 my calendar of
the Agincourt and pure XP boosts
solution if you send your email to I can
email you the entire protocol thank you
next question please what are the
advantages of BD back tech / biomérieux
vitex systems that's an excellent
question actually the vitex method is
very common and very straightforward to
use on many customer microphone through
the discussion of those customers we
know that sometimes the test results
it's inconclusive the test needs to be
repeated or the microcosm needs to be
identified using other method that's
that's why the sequencing method offers
a better alternative because you have MS
and authority we need their sequence
alignment thank you and next
next the question please okay this next
person has two questions for you the
first one is have you used this
technique for identification
identification of microbial pathogens in
clinical samples directly yes we have
many customers who publish papers
identifying the microtubules in clinical
samples if your email i can send your
long list of those papers thank you and
next question please ok the next
question is in case of fungal
contamination how could you use this
technique with a combination of
contamination that's an excellent
question if you have a mixture of fungus
or other microorganisms we have three
alternatives that you can choose either
in this terminal rflp or you can do XP
PC detection or you can do sequencing
using library constructed from amplicons
during the pardon I amplification thank
you and next question please what do you
mean by XP pcr that's an excellent
question XP pcr it's a technology that
utilize universal priming technology
in which after a few cycles of teasing a
new convert multiple partner based
multiplex pcr into a PCR reaction that
based only using one pair of pcr primers
in this way you minimize the annealing
bias introduced by different primers and
um define oh and becomes full session
using the same pair of primers in this
way the multiplex PCR is much more
quantitative and accurate over the
conventional multiplex pcr thank you
very much we have time for one last
question if we didn't get yours we will
follow up with you via email so the last
question is is very limitation for
identification if the microbe is
isolated on a highly selective a bar
that's an excellent question actually
for sequencing believe when we amplify
the our DNA sequence the polymerase does
not really care where your denominating
they come come from influence growing
simpler go played or complicated agar
plate as long as in provided in the
pre-race raise the genomic be named it
will amplify so therefore there is no
intention on identifying microbes that
work really not complicated I've got
played thank you very much
thank you dr. woo do you have any
further thoughts you'd like to share
with us today not really I just would
like to invite people to come to our
website on sites web site to look at our
products and if you have any further
questions you can No thank you very much
I would like to thank our speaker dr.
Rowe as well as our sponsors IX for
making it possible to bring this
presentation to you today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through februari 2016 you'll receive an
email from us alerting you when it's
available on demand and posted on lab
routes comm you're welcome to for this
announcement to any colleagues to
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast see you next time